the again and customs can't check every
container but they were suspicious about
this one because it came into the
country via a convoluted route from the
Democratic Republic of Congo through
South Sudan to the Ugandan border inside
tropical timber but the tree trunks had
been hollowed out and filled with ivory
we're able to intercept free by 20
containers which was declared to have
been containing oak tree to Vietnamese
nationals have been arrested and
officials believe the ivory was headed
for the Asian market 325 elephants had
to be killed for this ivory there were
also the scales of hundreds of
endangered pangolins for us this is one
of the biggest catch or interception of
goods which are prohibited to be traded
in under the international wide left
protocol or cites so we believe that
this is a vise that's right
international in nature for the to
express that we are having we are now
integrating them are taking statements
from them the smugglers hadn't reckoned
with state-of-the-art scanners at this
border crossing but as long as there is
a market they will be smuggling
you